[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'est ni chanteur ni acteur ni
réalisateur et pourtant il a bel et bien
une renommée internationale cette
renommée il l'a acquise en défendant
avec ardeur son métier de boucher en
déclarant haut et fort son amour de la
bonne viande cette passion et cette
façon atypique de l'exprimer lui a
ouvert les plus grandes tables les plus
grands restaurants il a même inspiré le
personnage principal d'un roman et puis
cela lui a permis de délivrer des
messages forts sur l'élevage et
l'agriculture française quitte à
bousculer et quitte à déranger parfois
pourquoi qu'est ce qui ne va pas ou
qu'est ce qui n'allait pas dans ce monde
agricole avant qu'ils n'y entrent on va
lui poser toutes ces questions bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenue yves
marie le bourdonnec merci d'avoir
assisté notre invitation au sénat je
rappelle qu'on est ici dans le dôme
tournon qu'est ce qui ne va pas d'après
vous dans les élevages français qu'est
ce que vous êtes venu bousculer dans cet
univers alors je vais parler d'une
espèce particulière le bovin pour le
cochon la volaille l'agneau ça se passe
plutôt bien les très bons élevages sont
parfaitement identifiés dans le bovin
c'est plutôt une c'est l'histoire qui
fait qu'on n'a pas le modèle idéal
depuis tout le temps le la viande rouge
n'était pas une partie importante de
notre consommation de viande on mangeait
plus tôt du cochon de la volaille et la
viande rouge était réservé plutôt à la
campagne dans l'est dans les fermes on
mangeait le bovin qui avait travaillé
les champs mais on le mange et à la fin
de sa vie ou lavage qui avait donné du
lait pour faire des très bons fromages
et on la mange et la fin de leur vie à
la fin se dit également ce qui fait
qu'on mangeait toujours des animaux très
âgé et c'est pour ça qu'on a dans toutes
les provinces françaises une spécialité
de viande bouillie la garbure la
carbonade le pot-au-feu le bourguignon
avec chaque région a son plat de viande
bouillie de boeuf
traditionnels donc ça c'était avant
merci non l'attiser c'est juste que la
fin du 19e siècle et puis et puis il a
fallu faire venir la viande rouge en
ville parce qu'elle se consommait
vraiment principalement à la campagne et
quand on arrive quand on amène la viande
rouge en ville donc c'est la fin du
19ème début du xxème on vient dans un
dans un endroit rural urbain qui est
plus rapide qui va plus vite et on n'a
pas le temps de mijoter très longtemps
on doit tout on préfère grillé on peut
on préfère retire on préfère
faire sauter rapidement les aliments et
c'est à ce moment là que eddy riva rit
on s'aperçoit à ce moment là que nos
animaux sont pas tout à fait adapté à la
consommation de la viande moderne c'est
à dire une consommation de viande rouge
très peu cuite quand on fait griller
rôtir ou ou même quand on mange la tare
terre forcément là il ya très très peu
de lui son qui en rentrent en jeu et nos
viandes ont un défaut particulier alors
qui est qui n'est pas grave mais qui est
un défaut particulier quand on veut le
manger de cette façon c'est qu'il a un
taux de collagène très important parce
que il y à un
élément qu'on n'a jamais pris en compte
dans notre élevage c'est là la précocité
de nos animaux voyez je vais schématiser
toutes les races françaises de la
limousine en passant par la normande la
blonde d'aquitaine que je pourrais vous
en citer une cinquante une cinquantaine
elles sont toutes adultes aux alentours
de 40 à 50 mois notre opposé c'est le
monde britannique le monde anglo saxon
encore une anguille anglaise une aire
fort d'une longue horn elle est adulte à
18 mois ça ça change toute la donne
c'est à dire que quand elles arrivent à
l'âge adulte on peut déjà lui donner la
qualité nécessaire pour faire une viande
de qualité très vite donc elle a un taux
de collagène très bon mois jusque jeudi
à mes éleveurs utiliser une race locale
pour les femelles utiliser une salaire
quand vous êtes en auvergne une normande
quand vous êtes en normandie ou en
bretagne une une montbéliard dans l'est
mais c'est vous la mariée avec un
taureau britannique comment ils
réagissent et éleveurs parce qu'on sent
ce discours qui est qui est très dur
aujourd'hui avec les agriculteurs avec
les éleveurs est ce que vous les sentez
aussi en souffrance parce qu'ils sont
parce qu'on leur demande beaucoup parce
qu'ils doivent répondre à tout un tas de
normes aussi et de ce que vous dites là
aujourd'hui oui oui
les éleveurs sont catastrophés l'élevage
français est en faillite les vaches
france est en faillite jamais un éleveur
ne pourra gagner sa vie dans le monde
actuel de la production c'est impossible
modèle français est terminée il faut
bien en prendre conscience et
épouvantable elle dira peut-être mais il
faut l'entendre et il ya c'est pas pour
ça que il faut tout jeter à la poubelle
il ya aussi deux de très bonne race
qu'il faut utiliser qu'il faut arrêter
en fait deux obsédés de la race pure
c'est comme si vous demandiez à un
vigneron de d'élaborer le meilleur vin
du monde mais en n'utilisant qu'un seul
cépage forcément ils oracle un seul
caractère qu'une seule particularité le
meilleur steak du monde forcément issue
d'un métissage entre plusieurs races en
plus entre plusieurs animaux qui vont
apporter leur qualité génétique leur
qualité d'histoire lors leur
particularité pour réaliser la meilleure
viande du monde donc je commence à être
entendu j'ai très peu été entendus au
départ j'ai eu ma bulle moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer plusieurs
ministres de l'agriculture de leur
expliquer j'ai le secret mois pour pour
sauver l'élevage français je le jeu le
jeu peut le donner à n'importe qui qui
voudra l'entendre et c'est rien
d'extraordinaire c'est très pratique et
dans le monde entier il y a qu'en france
qu'on doit pas le faire
mais
voilà je suis pas très écouté c'est vrai
que c'est pas très écoutés ni par mes
pairs qui ont beaucoup de mal à entendre
le discours que du coup on a tort de
décerner des prix aux meilleurs
charolais on s'y prend mal c'est de la
pure génétique décerné à un prix à une
vache charolaise au salon de
l'agriculture s'est décerné un concours
c'est un concours de beauté on va lui
dit on va dire qu'elle a la
caractéristique idéal et la musculature
idéale elle a le le
éventuellement les cornes parfaite la
lure parfaite mais ça va pas vous donner
une qualité de viande idéal alors les
éleveurs sont pointés du doigt sur une
question de la maltraitance animale
c'est quelque chose dont on parle
beaucoup mais votre métier on fait aussi
les frais le métier de bouche est aussi
souvent attaqué il ya comme un discours
anti viande qui se développe depuis
quelques années est ce que ça vous
touche
il faut en être conscient en tout cas
il y a un discours anti viande alors
chacun discours d'ailleurs il ya aussi
des attaques violentes contre lé oui
notamment des antispécistes suisse
estime jean d'un sujet sérieux et
probables non j'en ai subi les
conséquences de parfois vous avez vous
même été attaqué oui oui j'ai eu
quelques attentats sur certains de mes
boucherie
je peux comprendre que l'élevage
industriel choc je peux comprendre que
on n'y croit plus et moi même je crois
pas à ces tel élevage industriel à la
production de viande tel de façon
importante comme ça je ne crois pas et
je suis certain je suis convaincu même
que dans les 20 ans qui viennent on aura
plus cette production ça n'existera plus
mais on sera ton restera des
consommateurs de viande on n'a pas je
vais pas dire qu'on n'a pas le choix
c'est que c'est dans la logique des
choses c'est notre c'est notre profonde
nature
vous en est issue que ça même quand vous
voyez le véganisme qui se développe
aussi vous en vrille et quand je parle
je vais gagner oui et non mais le bond
est une tendance le véganisme c'est 0 2%
je crois de la population voilà les
végétariens ces deux ou trois pourcent
la vl de la population alors j'ai rien
contre eux toute façon il faut réguler
la consommation de viande il faut
arrêter de manger de la vie à deux de
vouloir de la viande en quantité énorme
c'est absurde la viande ne peut pas être
bradée à ne peut pas être faite
n'importe comment ça ça réclame ça
implique d'abord beaucoup de choses le
paysage le tout une économie beaucoup de
beaucoup d'emplois et il faut pas le
battre et il faut pas le faire n'importe
comment il faut le faire de en
conscience
mais les végétariens les vegan ils
fondent leur leurs théories et leur
idéologie même sur la souffrance animale
la sensibilité animal qui existe dans la
loi depuis 1976 qu'est ce que vous
faites de cet argument qui vous parle de
sensibilité animal la souffrance animale
c'est vrai que quand on voit un élevage
industriel c'est affreux pour un animal
de vivre de cette façon c'est affreux il
ya rien de mieux qu'un animal qui vit
dans la nature
c'est bien cette façon c'est par là
qu'il faut aller c'est qu'aucun de mes
éleveurs ne travaille de façon
industrielle encore une fois je reviens
ce que je disais ça n'existera plus
c'est forcément ça existera pu donc le
combat des vegan est juste là dessus il
faut arrêter de faire souffrir les
animaux bien entendu il faut qu'ils
vivent heureux et son anonymat le
redonne une viande bien meilleure après
la question est de savoir si on doit
manger ou non un animal
ça a toujours été comme ça j'ai pas eu
ce j'ai été élevé à la campagne dans une
ferme et j'aime énormément les animaux
j'aime les animaux j'aime la compagnie
des animaux c'est j'ai une proximité
avec comprenez que ça paraisse paradoxal
à celui qui aime tellement l'animal
qu'ils refusent de le manger il ya deux
types d' amour des mots vous dit il ya
tout ça il ya les aliments non khl qui
m'a élevé ma toujours expliqué qu'il ya
des animaux qui nous accompagnent dans
la vie le chien qui nous aident à
chasser le loup a gardé le cheval qui
nous qui nous aident à travailler et
puis à les animaux que l'on consomme que
l'on mangé un et on ne les aime pas tout
à fait de la même façon mais ils doivent
en tout cas tous les deux être heureux
et vivre correctement c'est quoi ce lien
que vous avez avec les animaux ça vient
de mon enfance en fait moi je suis à
cheval enfants de la dass j'ai été
retirés de la garde de mes parents
j'étais tout petit et puis j'ai été
confiée à mon oncle et ma tante en
bretagne j'avais 5 6 ans il vivait dans
une ferme et il y avait des animaux
parce que c'était une petite ferme où il
y avait des cautions des vaches des
veaux des poules et donc j'étais tout de
suite émerveillé par ces éléments il y
avait aussi des chiens il y avait aussi
des chevaux et j'étais émerveillée par
tous par tous ces animaux et mon oncle
qui est un homme très sage qui m'avait
ma toujours expliqué le lien à l'animal
qu'il fallait respecter les animaux
qu'il fallait les rendre heureux et mais
qu' il n'y avait pas de problème à le
manger enfin jamais jem a eu jamais eu
de problème vous n'y voyez pas de
paradoxe je n'y vois aucun paradoxe
j'ai un document vous vous transmettre
yves marie le bourdonnec c'est une
archive qui nous vient des archives
nationales qui ne sont pas retenues
elles sont nos partenaires sur cette
émission c'est un menu l'elysée alors
j'explique pour le vouvoyer mais je
voudrais aussi le dur pour les gens qui
nous écoutent c'est un menu de l'elysée
servi 18 octobre 1953 en l'honneur de sa
majesté la reine des pays bas et de son
altesse royale le prince bernhard à ce
moment là le président de la république
c'est vincent auriol et je lis le menu
caviar blinis au sarrasin mousseline
bayonnaise et selle d'agneau arlésienne
est-ce que d'après vous la diplomatie se
joue aussi
sur la table et sur la viande que la
france est en capacité de présenter
sûrement sûrement bien entendu oui oui
ça c'est l'histoire de secours manche
c'est notre histoire
quand on mange une viande ça on mange à
une partie du paysage une partie de
notre pays et c'est pour ça que c'est
très important de respecter ça et de ne
pas délocaliser ou deux de ne pas
nourrir nos animaux avec des produits
qui viennent d'ailleurs c'est le terroir
c'est fondamental dans notre même une
marque à l'étranger c'est une marque un
dîner officiel l elysée sans viande ça
vous paraît très fou je pense oui je
pense oui ça ne représente pas
l'agriculture française il faut que ça
représente à vos yeux l'agriculture
france et pourtant quelque chose qui
pourrait arriver si un jour un
écologiste arrivée au pouvoir à l'elysée
on pourrait imaginer que au moins une
fois par semaine pour le symbole il n'y
ait pas de viande à table alegre ou même
plus que ça sûrement qu'on régulera de
façon le fera on va réguler notre
consommation de viande mais elle ne dit
pas un il disparaîtra jamais
elle ne disparaîtra pas parce que si on
arrête de consommer de la viande toute
une partie des animaux que l'on connaît
vont disparaître face on allait jusqu'à
c'est complètement utopique de le penser
si on ne mange plus de steak il y aura
plus de vaches
il est pas possible d'élever une vache
uniquement pour avoir du lait un bon vin
une bonne viande un bon fromage c'est la
gastronomie
française cette phrase est signée du
communisme et vous le savez celle ça
vous a fait plaisir d'entendre ça et
bien sûr il faut que les politiques se
défendent ça c'est très important c'est
très très très important et c'est pas
une histoire de gauche ou de droite et
c'est pas une histoire non plus de
catégories sociales la bonne viande mon
fromage les bons vins doit être
accessible à tout le monde et ça l'est
une viande rouge peut coûter très cher
si on veut la partie la plus rare dans
qu'elle coûtera très cher mais il ya
certaines parties qui valent beaucoup
moins d'argent je vais donner un exemple
très concret si vous voulez le tournedos
du centre du filet il peut coûter 200
euros le kilo mais si vous voulez à un
steak dans la bavette elle peut vous
coûter 20 euros le kg voire même 15
euros le kilo pour un burger ont 10 pour
un steak haché vous observez quand même
un discours qui change de dans vos
clients dans les boucheries des
mentalités qui change des questions qui
se pose est ce qu'on vous pose la
question des questions aujourd'hui qu'on
ne vous posait pas il ya dix ans oui il
ya ya ya je pratique ce métier depuis
trente cinq ans il ya trente cinq ans là
le bien-être animal ça parlait à
personne l'élevage ça va parler à
personne
aujourd'hui bien entendu on nous demande
comment c'est là on nous demande d'abord
d'où ça vient qui l'a élevé qui est la
personne il faut qu'on soit capable de
raconter l'histoire de l'éleveur c'est
très important et qu'il a élevé les
comment il a été élevé et de quelle
façon il a été élevé et pourquoi il est
élevé à tel endroit et pour cela il faut
être capable de raconter cette histoire
vous imagineriez que un jour qui est des
débats de tels débats en france
d'ailleurs ça vous permet de parler de
votre métier mais vous imaginez ça un
jour à l'époque non à l'époque non non
mais je suis content parce que je il ya
30 ans quand je débutais moi j'ai tout
de suite voulu aller vers l'excellence
dans ce métier j'ai tout de suite voulu
aller vers les meilleurs produits et
j'étais pris pour un farfelu à l'époque
je me souviens quand j'ai commencé à
faire de la nature à sion pour le boeuf
c'était il ya vingt ans on me prenait
pour un fou et aujourd'hui c'est devenu
presque une mode mais on ne prenait
comme pour un vraiment pour un fou il
est du coup les débats d'aujourd'hui
finalement ce sont les bienvenus ça vous
permet de la péta tout le monde en ait
pris conscience c'est très important on
il y aura toujours des carnivores il y
aura toujours des consommateurs de
viande et on doit être on doit être
consommateur de viande en conscience
c'est très important je crois que vous
avez des enfants de garder qui garçons
cinq garçons que dis-je allant deux kivu
sur les deux qui sont bouchées voilà qui
vous suivent dans le métier de boucher
quelle est leur approche aes qu'ils sont
aussi comme cette nouvelle génération
avec une sensibilité particulière celle
dont on parlait tout à l'heure
l'écologie la maltraitance animale ou
est-ce qu'ils vous suivent exactement
comme vous dans la même alors j ai alors
c'est ils ont fait leur propre parcours
parcours ils ont commencé chez moi puis
ils sont allés voir ailleurs comment ça
se passe mais ils ont cette conviction
la même que moi que la viande doit être
un produit respecte et qui l'animal doit
être respectée le tout toute la filière
doit être respectée et il en semble
parfaitement conscience ils ont le
sentiment que leur métier encore de
l'avenir ou pas parce qu'on dit qu'un
jour les insectes que vous voyez vous en
servir d aider les de toute façon si on
mange moins de viande et s'il ya moins
de production de viande il faudra
d'autres sources de protéines c'est
certain bien sûr de notre alimentation
va être beaucoup plus varié dans les
années qui viennent alors revenons un
peu sur votre parcours à vous le métier
de boucher vous nous en avait un petit
peu parlé vous y venez aussi revoir tout
cas votre amour des animaux vous vient
de votre enfance et le métier de boucher
à quel moment vous avez le déclic alors
le dévoile le déclic c'est des gestes du
boucher en fait j'ai donc je vivais à la
campagne chez mon oncle et ma tante en
bretagne et nous avions une personne qui
venait deux fois par an pour abattre un
animal pour notre propre consommation
d'accord donc ils venaient pour abattre
un veau ou un cochon ou un boeuf et que
l'on découvre on voyait des coupes et on
le veuille mettre à mort l'animal le
dépecer le découper et en même temps le
on l'aidait à lamballe et on est au
congélateur alors ce personnage pour moi
était ambigu parce que mon oncle
m'autorisait à avoir des animaux à
élever des animaux mais en tout en
expliquant tout le temps attention on
n'élève pas des animaux comme ça juste
pour le plaisir de les câliner et pour
uniquement pour ça il faut un didier un
but ouais c'est pas un doudou à l'animal
s'est il faut qu'il a un but dans qu'il
faut que tu te commercialise un moment
donné il faut on ne va pas se relever
des chèvres tout début on va pas se
retrouver que des chèvres
on va être envahi par les chèvres donc
il y avait une règle quand la mon petit
chevaux atteignait ces trois mois il
fallait que j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qu'il
l'ait acheter je devais l'avoir vendu
très souvent je finissais par le donné
que les chapes aux mains de monsieur
kabel ce fameux boucher s'appelait
monsieur kabel et donc sur monsieur
kamel est à la fois un monstre pour moi
puisque il habite il la battait l'animal
que je que je m'étends et en même temps
je découvrais un artiste des gestes
quand je le voyais travailler j'ai été
subjugué par ses gestes c'est cet homme
que je trouvais un taux sanguinolent un
peu brutal un peu un peu brut de
décoffrage je le trouve je le trouvais
splendide quand il travaillait et est
donc je restais hypnotisé par ces par
ses gestes
et puis un jour à table que dans lors
d'un repas de famille quand on demande
aux enfants qu'est ce que vous allez
faire quand vous serez grand mes cousins
pouvait dire
pompiers astronautes ou et moi je dis je
veux faire le métier de nos cieux kabel
et là ma tante était
très interloqué et puis très très
inquiètes amélie mai mais ils se marient
taux qui est un garçon si sensible
comment tu veux être bouché ça
paraissait incompatibles je n'avais pas
la force de caractère qui me permettait
de dire jeu et qui permettait
d'argumenter donc jeu il m'a fallu du
temps j'étais tout j'avais 9 ans quand
ça m'arrivait et j'ai suivi mon parcours
scolaire normal et je savais qui après
le collège il fallait aller vers vers le
métier manuel vers la boucherie passer
un ca paie donc j'ai insisté et là mon
oncle m'a dis très solennellement il
faut
je danger j'étais le choix après la
troisième soit j'allais vers la voie du
bac soit à faire le métier et il m'a dit
avant toute chose qui aurait passé un
été à l'abattoir municipal de tréguier
c'est en bretagne et tu vas tu vas
travailler avec les bouchers pour voir
s'il peut être que ce métier finalement
tout va te dicter peut-être que non mais
il faut quand même que tu sois confronté
j'ai fait mon ancre entre guillemets mon
stage de 3e et oui il y avait pas ça le
troisième à l'époque je les fais c'est
une histoire de famille pour vous la
boucherie marie le bourdonnec et bien je
ne le pensais pas jusqu'à encore une
dizaine d'années parce que donc enfants
je vivais avec mon oncle et ma tante je
n'ai pas été élevé par mes parents et à
l'âge de 40 ans je j'ai perdu mon papa
mon papa est décédé et j'ai très peu
connu ma maman je j'ai été séparé de la
maman j'avais un an et demi donc je vais
vraiment très peu connue et elle était
originaire d'avignon et ma soeur qui
fait du théâtre à avignon tous les ans
et me dit une année à cette époque là je
vais les je vais aller voir enquêter
pour voir si je rencontre des gens de la
famille de notre maman et elle revient
de à la fin de l'été et me dire là ils
ont appris une chose extraordinaire tous
les hommes de la famille de maman était
boucher de père en fils et en fait je
m'apercevais que j'étais amoureux de ce
métier pas le coup de foudre c'est lé
geste mais en fait je l'avais en moi
dans les gènes je l'avais dans les
jeunes et je le vois aujourd'hui mes
enfants qui qui quand j'étais gamin
quand il était jeune très jeune et mets
pas mon métier parce que il m'accaparer
trop mon métier je travaille beaucoup je
ne m'occupais pas assez d'eux donc ils
m'ont toujours dit on fera jamais ton
métier c'est moche la boucherie et puis
finalement ils sont venus par un effet
détourné esseulé mais deux aînés sont
passionnés par ce métier et vous ayez
prononcer le mot d'artistes oui monsieur
kamel parce que sur votre sur le site
maison le bourdonnec vous affichez trois
piliers le savoir de la filière l'art de
la maturation et l'art de la découpe de
l'envol collard important vous vous
sentez artistes dans sur la découpe oui
c'est vrai cela oui je revendique oui
oui mais moi j'ai je pense avoir même
mis au point une école de découpe
particulière sayadiya il ya 2 qui a deux
grandes écoles enseigné dans la découpe
l'école française et l'école japonaise
et ça vient de deux choses particulières
c'est que leur approche du bovin est
tellement compliqué qu'il faut être un
artiste enfin il faut être un artisan
reconnu pour savoir le travail et
contrairement aux anglais qui ont
l'animal idéal et qui ont pas se soucier
de savoir dans quel sens il faut le
découper et les deux choses qui nous est
aux oppose les anglais les japonais et
les français dans notre art c'est que
nous nous avons une approche
chirurgicale
de la viande qu'un chaque muscle est
important chaque muscle à sa destination
il ne faut jamais tranché un muscle et
le japonais a une approche géométrique
de la viande ils sont dans le contre
fibre viande est composé de fibres ils
sont tout le temps à la recherche du
contre-pied le tranchage idéal et bien
moi j'ai marié mais ces deux écoles en
allant au japon en accueillant des
apprentis japonais et en envoyant des
des francs des apprentis français au
japon j'ai marié ces deux écoles parce
qu'il faut avoir ces deux approches là
parce que pour réussir la viande idéal
la meilleure viande du monde il faut
avoir ces deux écoles on valorise pas
assez cette filière de la boucherie ça
reste des voies vers lesquels on va
quand on n'arrive pas à faire une
filière générale vous vous regrettez ça
vous le sentez encore où c'est en train
de changer c'est vrai que très longtemps
rentré dans un métier manuel ça m'est
arrivé quand je lis à 35 ans c'était
presque être puni de ne pas avoir réussi
à l'école alors pour dans mon cas ce
n'était pas le cas j'avais un parcours
scolaire normal mais très souvent un
élève qui arrive dans l'aveu dans
l'avenir la voie du mat du métier manuel
émis un peu par punition tu
n'apparaissait l'école donc on te met
dans une voie secondaire et ça
malheureusement ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à nos métiers a pas
seulement la boucherie la pâtisserie la
cuisine plein de métiers qui sortent de
ces filières la sort de sa comment
évoluer ça eh bien on an depuis 10 15
ans il ya une nouvelle de nouvelles
façons de devenir boucher ou
ou d'autres métiers manuels c'est les
certificats de qualification professeur
qui permettent à des soi des élèves qui
ont changé de voie scolaire soit des
gens qui ont une profession et qui ont
décidé de changer de venir vers ces
professions là et on a toute une
nouvelle population qui arrive qui sont
merveilleux pour moi parce que ça me
permet d'avoir des gens avec des esprits
très ouvert et qui sont prêt à tout
entendre et qui ont un but précis ils
sont pas arrivés en punition ans métiers
sont arrivés parce qu'ils ont envie de
rentrer dans un métier concret ce ça nos
métiers nos métiers manuels ces métiers
très concret on travaille la matière et
ça me ça nous permet d'avoir d'avoir des
gens beaucoup plus motivés qu'ils n'ont
pas le même parcours j'ai des photos
pour vous il marie le bourdonnec et j'ai
d'abord celle ci à vous montrez vous
allez probablement le reconnaît c'est la
faute à des langues la casse un grand
chef des grands chefs avec lesquels vous
collaborez un désormais il n'y a pas que
alain ducasse fois que vous travaillez
aussi avec yannick alléno et alors c'est
intéressant parce que vous êtes quand
même au centre d'une grande chaîne qui
va de l'éleveur
après quelque chose importante moi quand
je collabore avec un chef je collabore
sondés sur l'histoire de gestes je joins
ne fournit pas de viande au chef parce
que ma filière est particulière parce
que mon modèle économique y est et je ne
vais pas les volumes nécessaires pour
pour fournir la la restauration par
contre quand un chef m'appelle il
m'appelle généralement pour parce qu'il
a une problématique techniques de
découpe et de découpe et notamment alain
ducasse qui m'avait appelé dans les
années 90 parce qu'il voulait qu'il
voulait mettre un morceau qui était
purement destinés à faire du pot-au-feu
et en faire une viande qu'on allait
grillé et moi en allant en argentine
j'avais découvert les costes y aller les
barbecue argentin et et je vais proposer
de faire du plat de côtes
un produit vraiment qui est fait pour
faire du bout du pot-au-feu de le
transformer par la maturation et en
faire un produit qui peut être grillé
sur un barbecue et mes skis mais ce qui
me frappe peut-être un peu plus encore
c'est que vous êtes capables de nous
parler des éleveurs que vous côtoyez au
quotidien et qui sont souvent quand même
un peu les mal aimés du métier un peu
mis de côté souvent en détresse on l'a
dit tout à l'heure et en souffrance et
vous côtoyez aussi ses chefs qui eux
servent pour des gens disons le qui ont
un porte monnaie bien fourni pour des
gens favorisés à quand une viande de
qualité accessibles aux plus pauvres un
restaurant étoilé aux plus pauvres c'est
pas compliqué de jongler comme ça entre
ces deux mondes entre ses mains ces
mondes de la précarité d'entre deux
extrêmes absolument pas non non non
absolument pas pu mieux encore comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure une une
vache à cette chose formidable d'avoir à
la fois des morceaux très cher et des
morceaux à des prix très raisonnables
c'est pas une somme d'argent c'est
important d'avoir de rencontrer des
grands chefs qui vu qu'ils apportent eux
lors leur accès à une clientèle très
particulière c'est vrai qu'ils ont des
moyens et qui nous permettent de
sublimer certains produits mais ça ça
fait ça fait remonter tout le tout de la
qualité de tout le reste donc c'est
important une autre photo alors là c'est
emmanuel macron vous le reconnaissez
probablement ce jour-là choisi de manger
un cordon bleu et on le voit la discuter
avec avec des enfants cordon bleu a
priori c'est pas tout à fait une viande
noble il a fait le bon choix ce jour là
c'est important qu'un président montre
l'exemple aussi sur la viande qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin d'un président doit
soutenir l'agriculture française donc
forcément c'est très important je
n'imagine pas un président qui disent
que la viande c'est pas possible qu'ils
ne soient pas consommateur de viande
c'est impossible alors d'un président ne
devrait pas mangé un cordon bleu alors
le corps dans blow ça peut être une
sombre
cochonneries
industriel mais ça peut être aussi un
très bon ça peut être adapté à un très
bon produit bonnes réponses une dernière
photo yves marie le bourdonnec que vous
le reconnaissez aussi sûrement c'est
aymeric caron qu'un journaliste écrivain
engagé à gauche très à gauche et lui
avait écrit un livre et vous le savez
aussi qui s'appelait nos steak ils
portent clairement le message inverse du
vôtre ce sont des gens aymeric caron
d'autres qui finalement font du mal à
votre métier ou font avancer le débat où
vous avez confronter vos points de vue
avec m oui alors malheureusement
aimerait que car on a toujours refusé de
me parler mais
ça m'est arrivé une fois mais j'ai pas
pu échanger beaucoup non je fais j'ai
même envie de vous dire tant mieux
qu'ils aient des végétariens tant mieux
guider vegan puisqu'on doit réguler la
consommation de la viande donc
finalement on a le même discours sauf
que moi je ne suis pas radical je vais
pas jusqu'à la suppression il faut qu'on
réduise considérablement notre
consommation bien c'est très très très
important est de toute façon on y va
vers la ce qui est important c'est qu'on
ait la meilleure viande possible et ça
ça va aider tout le monde ça va faire
que nos éleveurs voguait bien gagner
leur vie que les bouchers aussi vont
vivre puisque aujourd'hui la viande est
les plus vendus beaucoup dans les
boucheries des principalement vendu à
90% dans les grandes surfaces donc
peut-être que les bouchers là vont
pouvoir reprendre le métier et les
roulent les bouchons ont un vrai rôle
aujourd'hui pour pour réaliser la
meilleure viande possible ils ont ce
rôle de passeur entre l'éleveur et le
consommateur donc au contraire non je
trouve que tous et toutes ces personnes
vont dans le même sens sans une dernière
question et marie le bourdonnec en lien
avec ce lieu le lieu dans lequel nous
sommes ceux dont nous tournons du sénat
on est donc entouré de quatre statues
qui représentent chacune une vertu la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence laquelle de ces deux ses
vertus vous parle le plus pour moi c'est
d'éloquence mais oui parce que nous
sommes des passeurs ça veut dire que
nous sommes nous devons devons savoir
raconter l'histoire l'histoire de nos
éleveurs l'histoire de notre produit
c'est moi ça va manquer à une époque
j'ai eu j'ai eu la chance deux fois dans
ma vie de rencontrer un ministre de
l'agriculture et notamment stéphane le
foll une fois dans son bureau où je lui
ai dit très d'une façon très prétentieux
sûrement moi j'ai la solution pour
l'élevage et je lai je voulais vraiment
cette solution et j'avais envie de lui
expliquer cette solution malheureusement
nous étions à un an des prochaines
élections donc ça n'avait aucune
possibilité d'aller plus loin mais si
j'aurais aimé le convaincre je pense que
je n'ai pas suffisamment convaincu je
n'ai pas été assez éloquent donc je
travaille beaucoup cette chose là j'ai
eu l'occasion de faire un une conférence
tedx qui m'a beaucoup aidé pour mieux
m'exprimer pour mieux parler de mon
métier mieux parler de mon histoire est
et de ce que je fais l'éloquence et
essentiel c'est ce que j'ai le plus
besoin il voulait prouver aujourd'hui
vous l'avez eue c'est éloquence merci
merci infiniment yves marie le
bourdonnec devrait être invité dans un
monde un regard merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro sur
public sénat
[Musique]